avec nous un plateau marc perelman
bonjour marc vous avez interrogé il ya
quelques minutes le chef de l'aiea
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique on écoute d'abord un extrait
on est très inquiet de la situation en
général à l ukraine
pour ce qui concerne la sûreté et la
sécurité de toutes les installations
nucléaires et donc
un accident nucléaire ce serait un
événement majeur pour que ça arrive on
devrait se situer peut-être dans
scénario extrême
mais qui n'est pas à exclure donc dans
la sécurité nucléaire dans la sûreté
nucléaire il faut pas il faut jamais
laisser
livrés au hasard voilà raphaël grossi
très prudent n'y a pas de risque pour
l'instant mais tout peut arriver en fait
extrêmement volatile sur le terrain dans
la centrale de zappos ridja on l'a vu la
plus grande centrale d'europe
l'opérateur nucléaire l'ukrainien a
affirmé qu'il y avait eu des détonations
de munitions hier raphaël grossi m'a dit
que l'incident apparaît mineurs mais que
cela vient à la suite d'autres incidents
il n'est dit ce n'est pas un missile qui
va forcément frappé de façon délibérée
une centrale nucléaire mais comme on est
dans une zone de combat tout peut
arriver l'électricité peut être le coupé
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils expliquent
qu'ils négocient depuis quelques jours
avec les russes avec les ukrainiens et
la rencontrer leur ministre des affaires
étrangères respectifs lors d'un forum
diplomatique la semaine dernière en
turquie pour parvenir à un accord un
petit peu haddock improvisé pour
garantir la sûreté des sites nucléaires
etc l'ukrainien il affirme que les
négociations avancent mais qu'il faut
parvenir un résultat très rapidement
parce que le danger est là il n'est pas
à être écarté ils l'affirment qu'il
faudra que dans cet accord il est aussi
la possibilité d'inspecter les sites
nucléaires il dit que lui même est
disposé à se rendre en ukraine pour
faciliter cet accord donc c'est vrai
qu'ils affirment que la situation est
tendue elle est pour le moment sous
contrôle mais qu'il faut conclure un
accord vite parce qu'il ya danger
raphaël grossi à retrouver après journal
de 17 heures avec vous marc perelman mai
si beaucoup ont marre